[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER
HEIDEN: OK, hello.
So last time, we discussed
the pentose phosphate pathway,
which can serve as this
shunt from glycolysis
where glucose can be converted
to five-carbon ribulose
1, 5-bisphosphate
generating NADPH and ribose.
And this shunt
from glycolysis can
work with the non-oxidative
pathway, where
those five-carbon
units can then be
used by the non-oxidative
pathway to re-enter glycolysis,
giving cells and ability
to generate NADPH.
Now, we described that this
non-oxidative pathway can also
operate in the
reverse direction,
such that cells can take
products of glycolysis
and instead use them to
generate ribose for nucleotides
and avoid the
production of NADPH,
really giving cells
the flexibility
to either make NADPH
when they need it,
make ribose when they
need it, with the ability
to either operate in
this direction as a shunt
and allow NADPH to be produced
and material to re-enter
glycolysis for
further oxidation,
or to just generate ribose
if they have enough NADPH
and they simply need that
for nucleotide synthesis.
And we've spent
some time discussing
that NADPH is a key
molecule that allows cells
to do reductive reactions.
This includes the biosynthesis
of reduced carbon, which
is, of course, the
way that nature
stores energy for later use.
We saw this used as a
way to make reduce carbon
as carbohydrates
and photosynthesis.
And of course, it
can also be used
to generate fatty acids,
which is the most reduced
form of carbon that
all organisms can
have to store energy for later.
And the topic of today is
really to go through the pathway
that all organisms use to
produce those fatty acids
and lipids as a way to
store this energy as reduced
carbon for later.
Now, you'll notice
I drew up there,
as an introduction for the
reminder of what we talked
about last time with the
pentose phosphate pathways,
really layering
it on top of many
of the other pathways in
central carbon metabolism
that we've already discussed.
And I drew it that way because
I want to show that you already
know quite a bit.
If you think back to
the very beginning
where we had this complex
metabolic pathway chart, well,
we've already been able to build
quite a complex network of how
metabolism works.
And really, at this point,
you know the basics.
So today's lectures and the
three lectures after it,
so the four remaining lectures
that we have in this course,
we're going to cover an
awful lot of material.
Because, of course, we
have to discuss how all
of the remaining classes
of biomolecules-- lipids,
nucleic acids, proteins--
link into the rest
of metabolism,
which is an awful lot to cover.
But what you will see is
that, in understanding
the basics and the complexity
of what we've already described,
you actually know
already most of what
you need to know to understand
these remaining pathways.
That is nature continues to
repurpose the same relatively
simple reactions over and over
and over again to really build
this complex network that
is metabolism, including
this diversity of
macromolecules.
Now, of course, there's
a few bits of chemistry
that we still have to discuss.
We haven't discussed much in
terms of nitrogen metabolism.
But most of what you
need to know you've
already covered in understanding
glycolysis, the TCA cycle,
pentose phosphate
pathway, et cetera.
OK.
So now onto the
topic of the day,
which is really lipids
and fatty acid synthesis.
And so, again, I want to
reiterate that organisms
store energy as reduced carbon.
Fat is the most reduced
form of carbon to store.
And so if we're going
to generate fat,
we need a source of electrons.
Because if we're going
to reduce carbon,
something else has
to be oxidized.
That is those electrons
have to come from somewhere.
And as hopefully
as clear to you,
those electrons
will come from NADPH
because it forms this useful
electron donor for cells.
Now, it should also hopefully
be clear at this point
that, if oxidation
of carbon releases
energy, reduction of
carbon, therefore,
it needs energy input.
And so we're also going
to need a bunch of ATP
if we're going to make fat.
And so ADP and NADPH are
really the energetic drivers
of how we're going to
take more oxidized carbon
and reduce it to
build fatty acids.
Now, all organisms use
similar pathways to do this.
But, of course, the sources
of where the NADPH the
ATP come from can be different
depending on the organism.
And so we described
photosynthesis
is this process used by
photosynthetic organisms, where
they can use the light
reactions of photosynthesis
to make both ATP and NADPH.
And we described how
that ATP and NADPH
could be used to drive
synthesis of glucose
or other carbohydrates.
And effectively,
you can also imagine
that that same ATP and NADPH
from the light reactions
could also be used to
form the electron donors
and the ATP needed to
synthesize fats and lipids.
But of course, as
animals, we also
know that, if we eat too
much, we also have the ability
to store excess energy as fat.
And, therefore, we must also
have sources of NADPH and ATP
that we can use that
are non-photosynthetic.
And those, of course,
are the reactions
that we've already talked about
with glycolysis and the TCA
cycle, oxidative
phosphorylation as a way
to make ATP, as well
as NADPH from reactions
like the oxidative
pentose phosphate
pathway as a source of NADPH.
Now, eukaryotes will make
fatty acids in the cytosol.
And if you think
about why that is,
it's because mitochondria,
remember, is where
we did fatty acid oxidation.
And so fatty acid oxidation
is breaking down fatty acids.
Fatty acid synthesis--
building fatty acids.
One set of reactions is
in the cytosol, synthesis.
One set is in the mitochondria,
breakdown, makes sense.
Remember, compartmentalized
metabolism
gives you this ability to
favor different pathways.
Mitochondria is better
at oxidative reactions.
Cytosol is going to be better
at reductive reactions.
And also, this
compartmentalization
will keep catabolism and
anabolism separate, so another
example of a point that we've
been making over and over again
throughout this course.
Now, if we look up
here at our diagram,
we're going to make fatty acids
from two carbon acetyl-CoA
units, OK?
And so, remember, when we
broke down fatty acids,
most fatty acids
were even in number.
That's allowed us to break them
down into acetyl-CoA units.
Well, we're also going to build
them with two carbon acetyl-CoA
units.
And so this also contributes to
why most fatty acids in nature
have even numbers of carbons.
Now, you'll also recall
from our past lectures
that fatty acids are often
esterified to alcohols.
Those can be things
such as glycerol
based alcohols, which
allow us to form lipids,
either triacylglyerides, those
neutral lipids for energy
storage, or phospholipids
to form membranes.
And that, of course,
comes from a branch of--
glycerol, of course, comes from
dihydroxyacetone phosphate,
a molecule in glycolysis.
Now, of course, I'm not
going to draw acetyl-CoA now.
I'll draw it later.
But remember, it is not reduced.
And so that's where we're going
to need the electrons, NADPH
as well as ATP for the
energetic requirements
in order to take those
two carbon units,
build the acyl chain,
and ultimate reduce
them to make fat.
Now, when we do
this, you're going
to see that carbon dioxide,
as well as biotin--
OK, so you might be thinking,
oh, what's biotin used for?
It's a carboxylation reaction.
And so CO2 in a carboxylation
reaction involving biotin
is going to be required
for fatty acid synthesis.
However, you will also see
that that CO2 carbon is not
incorporated into
the fatty acyl chain.
And so you'll see that the CO2
is required, but ultimately
is added and released,
which is exactly
the same analogy to what we saw
when we did gluconeogenesis.
Remember, the pyruvate
carboxylase PEPCK reaction
in gluconeogenesis,
if you look back,
a CO2 was added to pyruvate
to make oxaloacetate and then
release later to generate PEP.
That helped drive the energetics
of that reaction, no net CO2
incorporation,
very similar thing
happening in fatty
acid synthesis.
Now, in animals, mammals,
much of fatty acid synthesis
is catalyzed by a giant single
polypeptide enzyme called
FASN or Fatty Acid
Synthase Complex,
which is, unlike
other complexes we
talked about where you might
have different polypeptide
subunits coming together
to form a complex,
this is one gigantic
polypeptide that
is able to catalyze many
of the enzymatic steps
of fatty acid synthesis.
Now, a bit of
trivia is that this
is different from plants
and bacteria, which
will carry out the exact
same enzymatic reactions.
However, it, rather
than using a giant fatty
acid synthase
complex, will have all
the different
enzymatic activities
broken up and catalyzed by
different proteins, separately
encoded polypeptides.
Now, all organisms will do
this using a protein called
acyl carrier protein.
And so acyl carrier
protein, you'll see,
is really analogous
to acetyl-CoA.
So it's a way to
add a thioester,
mark a separate pool, and will
carry the growing fatty acyl
chain as we synthesize it, OK?
So acyl carrier protein is part
of FASN, the big polypeptide
FASN in mammals that
catalyze this thing.
The acyl carrier
protein is not separate.
It's actually built in
to the sequence of FASN,
whereas acyl carrier protein
in plants and bacteria
is a small 9 kilodalton
protein, all right?
So in mammals, acyl
carrier protein-- part
of the fatty acids
synthase polypeptide
in plants and bacteria.
Acyl carrier protein is a
small 9 kilodalton protein.
And so what acyl
carrier protein looks
like is that as, part of
this 9 kilodalton protein
or sequence within FASN,
there is a serine residue.
Remember, serine has an
alcohol on its side chain.
And that alcohol on its side
chain has a phosphodiester bond
to a phosphopantothenate
group just
like we saw with coenzyme A.
So if you look
back in your notes
when I drew out coenzyme A, the
business end of the molecule
was right here with
the sulfur on the end
there being the one that
form the phosphodiester bond.
This one, rather than being
linked to a nucleotide,
in this case is linked to a
serine as part of a peptide.
And so this is why it's
very, very similar.
So this here is same as end
of coenzyme A. And so really
you can think of ACP,
Acyl Carrier Protein,
and coenzyme A, in some
ways analogous to how
we talked about NAD and NADPH--
same functionality,
in this case,
providing a sulfur to make
these thioester bonds as a way
to activate the acid on
the end of the fatty acid.
One used for synthesis,
one use for breakdown--
acyl carrier protein
used for synthesis.
Coenzyme A, acetyl-CoA is used
for oxidation, whereas in,
remember, NAD in NADP, one
was used to create an NAD,
NADH ratio that favored
oxidative reactions, the other
used to create an NADP,
NADPH ratio that favored
reductive reactions even
though the functionality
of the electron donor, in
the case of NAD and NADP
or, in this case, the carrier
function with the thioester
bond in ACP and coenzyme
A are analogous,
really allows you to mark
different pools to carry out,
in this case, anabolic and
catabolic reactions in cells.
So often, we will abbreviate
this just as we abbreviate CoA
as sort of CoASH or SCoA.
In this case, we're
going to use ACPSH
as an abbreviation for
Acyl Carrier Protein.
However, remember, just
like coenzyme A was
this giant molecule, it kind
of is a little misleading
to write it this way.
Acyl carrier protein is an even
bigger molecule, a 9 kilodalton
peptide in plants and bacteria.
And so, again, misleading
to write it this way
because it's really this
giant group linked to
and carrying the acyl chain.
OK.
Now, the first step in
fatty acid synthesis
is carboxylation of acetyl-CoA.
This is a very important
step of the process.
And it is not catalyzed
by the fatty acid synthase
complex, the fatty acid
synthase protein in mammals.
And so, in all organisms,
it is catalyzed
by a separate enzyme
abbreviated ACC, which stands
for Acetyl-CoA Carboxylase.
So ACC is a pretty
famous enzyme.
It's argued by many to
be the rate limiting
step in fatty acid synthesis.
And it makes sense
because you're
going to see this as we're
doing a carboxylation
reaction, big energetics here.
And that is, obviously,
as we learned
before, the steps
that you regulate
are the ones with the biggest
change in free energy.
So here's our old
friend, acetyl-CoA.
And what ACC carries out
is it carries out the
as biotin found in the
active site, which,
of course, can contain a CO2.
Just as a quick reminder,
how do we put CO2 on biotin
for carboxylic reactions?
And so, remember, CO2 is in
equilibrium with bicarbonate.
That bicarbonate can be
phosphorylated by ATP
to give this phosphobicarbonate.
And then that phosphate
can be released
to add the CO2 onto the active
biotin part of the enzyme.
That then carries
that CO2 and can
be used to transfer
the CO2 to carboxylate,
in this example,
acetyl-CoA to generate
this carboxylated acetyl-CoA
three-carbon molecule, which
is referred to as
malonyl CoA, all right?
So this is exactly
the same mechanism
that we described before
for pyruvate carboxylase
in gluconeogenesis, all right.
So I drew a part of it here.
Remember, if we draw
acetyl-CoA, in the enol form
of the molecule--
here we have our biotin, CO2.
If you look back at your notes,
we drew a mechanism like that.
And that allowed us
to, in that case,
take pyruvate and turn
it into oxaloacetate
and gluconeogenesis by
pyruvate carboxylase.
In this case--
identical reaction,
but this time you're
carboxylating acetyl-CoA
to make malonyl-CoA, right?
And it's malonyl-CoA
that ends up
being the substrate for
fatty acid synthase,
either the single fatty acid
synthase protein in mammals
or the same sets of
individually encoded activities
on different polypeptide
in plants and bacteria.
All right, so let's
draw this out.
So here's fatty acid synthase.
And so fatty acid
synthase has on it
two different acyl
carrier protein sites,
so two different
acyl carrier protein
encoded within the fatty acid
synthase polypeptide, each
of which have attached to them
this phosphopantothenate group
to make it an acyl
carrier protein.
Or there would be two
separate acyl carrier proteins
in plants and bacteria as
part of the complex that
synthesizes fatty acids.
And each of them can
pick up a acyl-CoA.
So here's a malonyl-CoA
and an acetyl-CoA.
Each of those can basically,
onto the acyl carrier protein,
exchange the thioester
bond with the CoA
to be a thioester bond with
the acyl carrier protein.
And so to get this
started, on one site
you'll end up going an
acetyl-CoA, exchange
the thioester bond, such
that you release the CoA.
And now, you have an acetyl ACP.
And on the other side--
a malonyl-CoA exchange
that thioester bond
releasing the CoA.
So you have a malonyl
ACP, all right?
So what does that look like?
Well, it'll look like this.
OK, so here we're going
to have basically--
I'll give you some color, so
you can see what's going on.
But here you have, on an
upper acyl carrier protein
site, the malonyl
group, so malonyl ACP.
And on this lower site, I
put on an acetyl ACP, OK?
So what happens
is you now release
the CO2 that was added by
acetyl-CoA carboxylase.
And that allows forming
carbon bond from here to here,
releasing the ACP
on the lower site
and generating this
longer four-carbon chain
on the upper acyl
carrier protein site.
OK.
Once you have this, now,
four-carbon chain, obviously,
if we're going to
make a fatty acid,
we have to reduce this carbon.
And so that's
exactly what happens.
And so how do we reduce it?
We've now seen this
many, many times.
And so if we use NADPH
as an electron donor,
oxidizing it to NADP+, that
generates this hydride ion
to electron carrier.
And now, we net reduce this
ketone to this alcohol, OK?
Next step is we're
going to remove water
across that bond,
just a dehydration.
All right.
Now, we can further reduce
that carbon-carbon bond.
The electrons, again, come
from NADPH as it's oxidized
to NADP+.
And that leaves us with a
reduced four-carbon fatty
acid, a four zero
fatty acid here
on this, esterified
by this thioester
to ACP, on the upper site
of fatty acid synthase.
OK.
All right, so what happens next?
Well, we can repeat this cycle.
So, now, we can have basically
this S-ACP on the lower site
pick up a malonyl-CoA,
release the CoA.
And then we have, down
here, another malonyl-CoA.
Now, they're esterified to
the ACP on the lower side.
All right, now, we can run this
exact same series of reactions
again.
OK.
That releases CO2, also releases
a free S-ACP on the upper site.
And now, we are left with this.
This now-- six-carbon
molecule with a thioester
now on the ACP on
the lower side.
Hopefully, you're
getting the point.
I can now take this through
the same cycles I took before.
But first, we're
going to use NADPH
to reduce this ketone to the
alcohol, the dehydration,
use NADPH again to reduce the
carbon-carbon double bond.
And we are left with now
this S-APP on the lower site.
I can now run this
cycle five times.
We'll add another malonyl-CoA,
this time to the upper site,
combine them.
Now, you have this growing
chain on the upper site,
reduction, another
malonyl-CoA to the lower site,
blah, blah, blah.
Run it five times.
Eventually, I'm going to end up
with a 16, 0, fatty acyl ACP.
And then I can take that,
exchange it back for a CoA.
And I end up with a 16
carbon fatty acyl-CoA
or palmitoyl-CoA CoA molecule,
such that all of the carbons
added came from
acetyl-CoA except for one.
All of that acetyl-CoA
was added by, first,
adding a CO2 via
acetyl-CoA carboxylase,
generating a malonyl-CoA
that's spending ATP
to put the carboxyl group on.
Because, of course, we
need it to spend an ATP
in the acetyl-CoA reaction.
And so seven cycles
were needed to generate
this 16, 0 fatty acyl-CoA.
And so those seven cycles
were seven ATP molecules.
I also needed 2 times 7,
or 14, NADPH molecules.
And that allowed me to
run this cycle 17 times
and make a fully reduced
16-carbon fatty acid.
Now, it turns out that
all of this activity
stops on the fatty acid
synthase molecule when it gets
to a 16-carbon palmitoyl-CoA.
But of course, as
we described before,
organisms have longer fatty
acids than 16 carbons.
And so 18-carbon and
longer fatty acids
are made in exactly the same
chemistry, same reactions
that we just described.
The only difference
is that they are not
made on the fatty
acid synthase complex.
So they're made in a
different location.
And so they're made
at the ER membrane
in eukaryotes, all right,
so the ER in eukaryotes.
Even though the
enzymes themselves
carry out the same reaction,
the enzymes that carry out this
are encoded by
different polypeptides,
so-called fatty acid
elongase enzymes.
Although the chemistry
is exactly what
we already described.
But those enzymes
act on the thioester
with the CoA, not the thioester
with the acyl carrier protein.
But it's still the same.
There's still one
ATP per acetylcholine
for two carbon unit
added because that
is needed to
carboxylate it to make
the malonyl-CoA because that's
what's driving the addition
and two NADPHs per
two-carbon unit
added to carry out the
reduction to take that carbonyl
from the acetyl CoA or
the malonyl-CoA that's
added as a two-carbon unit and
reduce it to the fully reduced
carbon.
OK.
And so that is how you
make saturated fatty acids.
So what about
unsaturated fatty acids?
Well, it is not that
you just stop and don't
make it fully saturated.
Nature, first, makes a
fully saturated fatty acid.
And then it comes back and
reoxidizes the fully saturated
fatty acid to introduce double
bonds in the right positions.
And so for unsaturated, so you
start with a saturated fatty
acid of the desired length.
So you make that first.
And then you use so-called
desaturase enzymes
to introduce double bonds at
the desired location, all right?
So it's a little
counterintuitive,
but this is effectively
why you end up
with double bonds at
the stereotyped places.
So, remember, the
delta 9 position
is the first place,
when we describe
the nomenclature of fatty
acids, where we always
put the first double bond.
Why does nature do it this way?
Well, it's very
hard to say that,
but you can imagine
evolution of how you would
get these enzyme activities.
It's hard to evolve a fatty
acid synthase complex that
would stop doing the
reduction reaction only
at specific locations.
And so you probably
first generate
these fatty acids fully
saturated because that's
the way an enzyme could
do it and then, later,
have a different enzyme
that can pick out
a location on a
saturated fatty acid
to introduce a double bond.
All right, so how can we
introduce a double bond?
Well, that's an
oxidation reaction.
And so if we're going to
do an oxidation reaction,
we need a place for the
electrons that we move.
So if we oxidize the fatty
acid, that's removing electrons.
Those electrons have
to go somewhere.
You might imagine, if we're
oxidizing a carbon-carbon bond,
we've seen that
reaction before when
we did succinate to fumarate.
Succinate dehydrogenase, that
was an oxidation reaction.
We used FAD.
We saw it with the
fatty acid breakdown
when we first put
the double bond in.
We used FAD.
And so, indeed, FAD is
used in this reaction,
but it does not work
like other FAD reactions
to carry out this oxidation.
For whatever reason, the way
desaturases work is different.
OK.
So these desaturase
reactions use oxygen
as a final electron acceptor.
And they work via a
mini-electron transport chain
in the ER in eukaryotes OK.
So it's a little bit of a
different weird mechanism.
But if we think here's
our carbon-carbon bond
that we're going to oxidize
to introduce a double bond
and desaturate our
lipid, so what is that?
Well, it's basically
this reaction.
OK.
So this is, rather than just
remove this as a hydride ion,
it turns out that
those electrons
go to oxygen, which, of
course, will generate one water
molecule.
But there's two
oxygen there, so you
need to generate a
second water molecule.
Those electrons have to
come from somewhere else.
And those electrons come from
this little mini-electron
transport chain.
So if we oxidize iron,
we can get electrons
from that reaction.
And so this ends up generating
a double bond in the fatty acid
with two of the electrons going
to oxygen and the other two
electrons coming from this
mini-electron transport chain
in this desaturase complex
in the endoplasmic reticulum,
all right?
And so, of course,
those electrons
have to come from somewhere.
So we have to re-reduce.
This iron we oxidize to
get the electrons from.
And so this works via
an electron transport
chain similar to
what we saw before,
where it's this whole series
of oxidation and reduction
reactions that does happen
to involve FAD and FADH2.
But ultimately, the electrons
are coming from NADH.
So oxidation of
NADH ultimately is
providing electrons that
together with oxidation here
lead to the reduction
of oxygen to water.
And you can, of course,
read more about this
if you're interested
in it, but it's
important to point out that
this process works by a slightly
different mechanism than
you might predict from sort
of the general principles of
the way most double bonds are
introduced in carbon-carbon
molecules in metabolism.
Why it works this
way is something
we can only speculate about.
OK.
Now, mammals only use
a disaccharase enzyme
that, in a fully
saturated fatty acid,
can only introduce a double
bond at the delta 9 position.
That is between carbons 9 and
10 of a fully saturated fatty
acid.
And that's because they only
have an enzyme complex that
does that.
So that is they can take an 18,
0 newly synthesized fatty acid
and they can make an 18, 1--
or we can make an 18, 1
delta 9 fatty acid, OK?
That's the only
desaturase enzyme
we have to put into a
saturated fatty acid.
That is to make completely
a de novo unsaturated fatty
acid, which is one
of the reasons why
we don't have a lot of
polyunsaturated fatty acids.
Now, we do have enzyme
complexes that work similarly
to these that can add double
bonds at other locations,
but they have to start having
a double bond already present
in those locations.
Many of those lipids have
to come from the diet.
And that's that concept of
essential lipids, something
that we have to eat from a plant
or bacteria that already has
a double bond there
in order to add
double bonds to make some of
our other polyunsaturated fatty
acids.
So that's how fatty
acids are made.
But as I alluded to
earlier, all of this
is taking place in the cytosol.
And if we're doing all of
this work in the cytosol,
maybe you notice
that we actually
have another problem
that nature has to solve.
And that is, because we're
doing all this from acetyl-CoA,
and so we have to have
acetyl-CoA in the cytosol
to have this work.
But acetyl-CoA, all
the ways we've talked
or most of the ways we've
talked about producing it,
happen in the mitochondria.
Remember, acetyl-CoA
can't get across
the mitochondrial membrane.
So we need a way
to get acetyl-CoA
out of the mitochondria into
the cytosol for this whole thing
to work.
Put another way--
so if we draw here,
here's glucose to pyruvate.
That's glycolysis.
Remember to turn that
pyruvate into acetyl-CoA.
We had to move the pyruvate
into the mitochondria.
That's where the PDH complex
was to generate the acetyl-CoA.
But if we need acetyl-CoA in the
cytosol for fatty acid synthase
to make fatty
acids, we basically
need a way to get that
acetyl-CoA back out
of the mitochondria in order
to generate fatty acids.
Other big source
of, remember, was
we start with a fatty
acid in the mitochondria,
run fatty acid oxidation.
Again, fatty acid oxidation
in the mitochondria
generates acetyl-CoA
in the mitochondria.
We're going to use it
to rebuild a fatty acid,
need to get it out of the
mitochondria into the cytosol.
Coenzyme A is not
membrane permeable.
Remember, we had shuttles
to get fatty acids
in the mitochondria.
We did the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction here
to begin with.
And so it's a problem
to get this giant CoA,
the CoA from the acetyl-CoA,
out of the mitochondria
into the cytosol.
OK.
So one solution to this,
to getting acetyl CoA
in the cytosol, is simply
to start with acetate, OK?
That is take the CoA
group off and just have
an acetate molecule.
And of course, acetate or
acetic acid, well, that's food.
That's vinegar.
All right, the salad you ate
has acetate in it, acetyl-CoA.
It can be in the cytosol.
We can make acetate if you
look back at your notes
about how we
metabolized alcohol.
So alcohol gets
metabolized to acetate.
And so that acetate
in the cytosol,
we can just add a CoA
group to it in the cytosol.
And how do we do that?
Well, we saw the reaction
to do this already.
OK.
And this is basically when
we added any fatty acid
to make a fatty acyl-CoA.
Remember, the free fatty acid
turned into a fatty acyl-CoA.
We add this reaction
where we used ATP.
We added the AMP to it.
And then that
[INAUDIBLE] pyrophosphate
can drive it forward with the
two pyrophosphate molecules
and take the AMP off
and adds a CoA group.
If you look back
in your notes, it's
the identical reaction to
how we made a fatty acyl-CoA.
Well, there's also an enzyme
that can act on acetate
and do this to make acetyl-CoA.
And that's great.
It's a way to make
acetyl-CoA in the cytosol
if you start with acetate.
However, this is
not the way it works
if you already have an
acetyl-CoA in the mitochondria.
And so if in the
mitochondria you already have
an acetyl-CoA--
so this can come from
pyruvate via the PDH reaction.
It can come from fatty acid
oxidation, this acetyl-CoA
in the mitochondria, all right?
Well, what do we talk about
doing with it in the TCA cycle?
Well, the TCA cycle, we
can use citrate synthase
to generate this
citrate molecule.
And it turns out citrate
itself can be used as a carrier
to export the acetyl-CoA from
the mitochondria to the side
cytosol, such that now, when
you have citrate in the side
cytosol, that citrate can now be
used where you basically carry
out the opposite of the
citrate synthase reaction
to regenerate acetyl-CoA
and oxaloacetate.
Well, if one direction
is favorable,
the other direction is
going to be not favorable.
And so you need energy input
in one of the directions.
And so this costs you ATP.
And this is carried
out by an enzyme
called ATP citrate lyase,
often abbreviated ACLY.
So ATP citrate lyase allows
you to basically reverse
the citrate synthase
reaction, such
that you can shuttle acetyl-CoA
out of the mitochondria
to the cytosol using
citrate as a molecule.
And then, of course,
that oxaloacetate
can be shuttled back into the
mitochondria via something
like the malate-aspartate
shuttle, which
we describe several
lectures ago,
as a way to make this
a complete cycle.
I want to spend a little bit
of time talking about this
because, here, a
lot of metabolism
begins to come
together, all right?
And so when do you want
to produce fatty acids?
We want to produce fatty acids
when you have a lot of ATP.
And so if you have
a lot of ATP, this
is a situation
where the TCA cycle
isn't going to want to run.
And so that favors citrate
export from the TCA cycle
into the cytosol.
Remember, citrate was
this important regulator
of glycolysis.
We talked about you
have a lot of citrate.
Let's slow down glycolysis.
Well, that citrate
in the side cytosol
also now provides a
source of acetyl-CoA
to take all that extra carbon
and turn it into fatty acids,
all right?
We also, in the process
of moving this out,
we generate oxaloacetate.
Remember, oxaloacetate,
of course,
is part of the
malate-aspartate shuttle.
We'll come back to
that in a minute.
But oxaloacetate in
the cytosol, that
was the product of the
pyruvate carboxylase reaction
to get oxaloacetate in the
cytosol so PEPCK can make
PEP and do gluconeogenesis.
And so the same thing is
also taking oxaloacetate
and putting that in this
cytosol where it's a good thing
to do gluconeogenesis, which
is something else that you
want to do if you have a lot
of excess ATP to store carbon.
And so this is really
set up in a way
that, now, you have your
citrate and oxaloacetate
in the cytosol, which
are the starting points
to generate either fat
or carbohydrate as a way
to store excess energy if you
have plenty of ATP around.
Now, it turns out that
oxaloacetate in the cytosol
is also beneficial
in another way
because it can be part of a
series of enzyme reactions
that also benefits
fatty acid synthesis.
And that's because it's a
substrate for an enzyme.
It can create a substrate.
It can create malate that's a
substrate for an enzyme called
malic enzyme, which is
another way to generate NADPH.
All right, so let's
go through this.
So remember, oxaloacetate
differs from malate
by an oxidation
reduction reaction.
So remember, we described malate
dehydrogenase in the TCA cycle
to turn malate into oxaloacetate
in the malate-aspartate
shuttle.
We pointed out that this
enzyme can run in reverse,
and so can be used to
regenerate NAD in the cytosol.
And this oxaloacetate
back to malate
as part of the
malate-aspartate shuttle
was a way to regenerate NAD
to help keep glycolysis going
as an alternative
to fermentation,
get those electrons
into the mitochondria,
so we give them to oxygen.
Well, this malate that's made
is the substrate not just
for the malate-aspartate
shuttle to bring electrons
into the mitochondria, but is
also a substrate for an enzyme
called malic enzyme.
And malic enzyme is
a way to make NADPH.
Well, how does this work?
OK.
So here's malate.
All right, so if we reoxidize
this alcohol to bring malate
back to oxaloacetate, so
that generates hydride ion,
which can, of course, be
given to a nicotinamide group,
the malic enzyme.
The nicotinamide group is
NAD+ to generate NADPH.
NAPDH is, of course,
useful for reducing power
to make fatty acids.
So what does this generate?
Well, this generates--
again, all I've done
is regenerate oxaloacetate.
OK.
This is oxaloacetate.
It turns out this oxaloacetate
is retained on the enzyme.
And remember, oxaloacetate is a
beta-keto acid, so acid group,
alpha, beta, beta-keto acid.
And beta carboxylation
is favorable.
You've now seen this
many, many times.
This is going to
generate enolpyruvate.
Enolpyruvate will want
to rearrange to pyruvate.
And so, effectively, I can
turn malate into pyruvate
and generate NADPH.
And that's what
malic enzyme does.
And if you look back at the
malate-aspartate shuttle,
we used oxaloacetate
to make malate.
And it was malate that was
sent back to the mitochondria.
Well, here, we can also
use it to make pyruvate.
And then the pyruvate can
go back to the mitochondria
and use pyruvate carboxylase
to generate acetate
via pyruvate
carboxylase as a way
to do anaplerosis for this
mini-cycle if you want.
A lot of moving
parts here, let me
be explicit about
what's going on
and show you how I can build
a series of reactions here
that is very useful if
I want to generate that.
OK.
So here's glycolysis.
Remember to run glycolysis.
I need a source of NAD+
plus for the GAPDH reaction.
If I'm not going to
ferment the pyruvate,
I need to deal with that NAD+.
Well, if I send now
that pyruvate here
into the mitochondria,
that pyruvate
can go through the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction,
make acetyl-CoA.
Acetyl-CoA combine with
oxaloacetate to make citrate.
OK.
Export that citrate from the
mitochondria to the cytosol.
Run the ATP citrate
lyase reaction.
Now, I have acetyl-CoA
in the cytosol
and can use that to
generate fatty acids.
And of course,
that requires NADPH
as reducing power to make
those fatty acids, OK?
So all series of reactions that
you've seen many, many times,
this is glycolysis,
pyruvate dehydrogenase,
citrate synthase, ATP citrate
lyase that we just described
and, of course, this over
here acetyl-CoA carboxylase,
of course, and fatty
acid synthase to do that.
All right, now, that's great,
but we have this NAD+ to deal
with.
And we need sources of NADPH
to balance all the electrons
to make this work.
Let's show how we
can incorporate
malate dehydrogenase and
malic enzyme as a way
to make all this balanced.
So if we take oxaloacetate
and make malate,
this is our malate
dehydrogenase reaction.
I've now regenerated the
NAD I need in the cytosol
to keep that carbon flowing
in from glucose to make
acetylcholine, right?
Now, I have malate.
I can use malic enzyme to
turn malate into pyruvate.
That's going to serve
as a source of NADPH
that I can use, again,
NADPH in the cytosol
to drive fatty acid
synthase in the cytosol.
Obviously, you need more
than one NADPH to do this,
but at least it generates
NADPH's reducing power
to make the fatty acids.
And of course, take
that pyruvate, bring it
back in the mitochondria.
I can run the pyruvate
carboxylase reaction.
And I'll regenerate oxaloacetate
in the mitochondria.
And now, I have a
balanced cycle where
I can run this cycle to turn
glucose carbon into acetyl-CoA
for fat and, in the process,
also make some NADPH's reducing
power to support my fatty
acid synthase reaction.
This is just one way that I
can take all these reactions we
talked about and
build a pathway that's
balanced, at least for the
NAD-NADH oxidation piece,
and gives us something useful.
Well, it gives us
ATP from glycolysis
and also gives NADPH from
the malic enzyme reaction
to do this.
And what does it cost me?
Well, it costs me a
bunch of ATP, right?
It cost me ATP here.
It costs me ATP there, of
course a lot of ATP up here.
But you're doing this when
there's energy excess.
You have plenty of ATP around.
And it's a way that
nature then can
use this high-energy, high-ATP
state as a way to store carbon,
ultimately, reduce carbon
is fatty acids that
can be used later when
times are not so good.
All right, so let's
spend a couple
of minutes talking
about the regulation
of fatty acid synthesis.
It's very straightforward,
not really
a whole lot to talk about.
You really only want to make fat
if you have high ATP-ADP ratio.
This is a situation excess
citrate in the cytosol.
And so high citrate, which,
remember, inhibits glycolysis--
well, high citrate is going to
activate fatty acid synthase.
OK.
The big step, though, is
acetyl-CoA carboxylase.
That's what makes
the malonyl-CoA.
That's the big
change in delta g.
By all the reasons we
talked about before, that's
a step you want to regulate.
And so it turns out that high
levels of palmitoyl-CoA--
that is the 16, 0
fatty acid, the product
of the fatty acid
synthase reaction.
This is going to inhibit
acetyl-CoA carboxylase.
It makes sense-- have a
lot of product around.
Stop making it.
Stop the step that costs
the most, that's hardest
to go back to generate it.
OK?
What's the other thing?
Well, you only want to do this
if cells have enough energy
to do it.
What's their energy charge?
ATP-AMP ratio-- if AMP is high,
you also want to inhibit ACC.
Low energy-- don't
try to make fat.
That's basically what you need
to know about the regulation
of fatty acid synthase.
Now, of course, that's
making fatty acids.
But of course, most
fatty acids are not
floating around free in nature.
They're stored as lipids.
And so just to remind
you, here is an image
from an earlier lecture.
These were the image of a fat
cell, as well as a plant cell
here.
They both have
these lipid droplets
that are filled with
these neutral lipids,
these triacylglycerides.
And so you want to store
the fatty acid for energy.
You put it into a
triacylglyceride,
pop it into a lipid droplet.
And now, you have
this efficient way
to store all this reduced carbon
without having to carry around
the weight of the water.
Or maybe you want to use this
to generate membranes, right?
Phospholipids, you need
to generate phospholipids.
Both triacylglycerides,
phospholipids
are built on this
glycerol backbone.
And I just want
to mention briefly
the pathway that
cells really use
or a pathway the cells use
to make these glycerol based
lipids.
And so as we talked
about before, here's
our old friend dihydroxyacetone
phosphate from glycolysis.
Remember, if we reduce this
ketone to the alcohol, that's
how we made glycerol.
It turns out, first,
before doing this,
the way nature does it is it
first adds the fatty acid.
So it takes the fatty
acyl-CoA, releases the CoA.
And you end up with
this intermediate, OK?
It's this molecule
that then you reduce.
Of course, you can
reduce it within NADH.
You can also reduce
it with NADPH.
And that gives us this
phospho-monoacylglycerol, OK?
So this molecule, with that
being the alcohol instead
of the ketone--
phospho-monoacylglycerol.
Now, come on, add
another fatty acyl-CoA.
Releasing the CoA, that gives
us a phospho-diacylglycerol,
so, now, a fatty acid esterified
to that middle carbon.
And then this
phospho-diacylglycerol,
we can remove the phosphate
to get just a diacylglycerol
and then generate a
triacylglycerol by putting
on a third fatty acid
from a fatty acyl-CoA,
releasing the CoA.
And now, we have this
triacylglyceride,
this neutral lipid that can be
packed into the lipid droplet
here and store energy as
reduced carbon for later.
That's great.
But what if we want to
make a phospholipid?
Well, I'll show you
briefly how this works.
Don't worry about
the details of this.
I just want you to have a flavor
for how this happens because it
illustrates another way
that nature repurposes
the same reactions
over and over again.
And so as one releases
this phosphate
from the diacylglycerol, it now
picks up head group on there.
And so one that can be
picked up is ethanolamine.
And the ethanolamine
comes from a molecule
called CDP ethanolamine.
If you're interested in the
structure of ethanolamine,
be reminded of that, you
can, of course, look it up.
But basically, it's ethanolamine
attached to a CDP group
releasing a CMP group, which
makes a phospho-ethanolamine.
And then that
phospho-ethanolamine
can be turned into
phosphatidylethanolamine.
A phospholipid
phosphatidylethanolamine
can be turned into
phosphatidylcholine.
And if you look
up the difference
between choline
and ethanolamine,
it's adding three methyl groups.
And we'll talk about how to
do that in one of the upcoming
lectures, all right?
And so here's two of
the major phospholipids,
phosphatidylcholine,
phosphatidylethanolamine.
They are added to
a diacylglyceride
by basically taking the
phosphate off and adding
a phosphate from CDP
ethanolamine releasing CMP.
What's CDP ethanolamine?
Well, it's very similar
to how we already
talked about with UDP glucose
in glycogen metabolism.
And so if you start with the
amino alcohol ethanolamine,
which itself is
made from serine,
but we don't have time
to talk about how,
this can basically be
phosphorylated by ATP
to put a phosphate
on the alcohol
to make phosphoethanolamine.
So you have a
phosphoethanolamine.
And then that
phosphoethanolamine
can react with a CTP,
releasing a pyrophosphate such
that the phospho from the
ATP is replaced by the CDP.
You end up getting
a CDP ethanolamine
with two pyrophosphate coming
off by a series of reactions
that, if you look
back in your notes,
will look identical to how
we made UDP glucose in making
glycogen. And then
the CDP ethanolamine
transfers the
phosphoethanolamine
onto the diacylglyceride
to give you
the phosphatidylethanolmine.
Why do I mention this?
Just because I want you to have
a flavor of how phospholipids
are made, realize that here is
a repurposing of a same series
and type of reactions as we
saw for glycogen metabolism,
but now to make
phospholipids, and also
to point out that it's
really expensive to make
a phospholipid, all right?
You need three ATPs just to
add this ethanolamine group
to there.
So that's actually
fairly expensive.
And so a lot of
energy goes into cells
building these phospholipids.
Now, for the last
bit of time today, I
want to return to a brief
topic of another lipid.
And that's this guy
here, cholesterol.
And so you'll remember
that cholesterol
is this complex ring structure,
lots of reduced carbon there.
It's a molecule
that mammals use,
if you recall, to keep
their membranes fluid.
Now, mammals, of course,
can make cholesterol.
And you probably have
heard about cholesterol
because high levels
of cholesterol
have been linked
to heart disease.
And so a lot of people talk
about what their cholesterol
levels are, something
doctors check a lot.
And this has led the
recognition that cholesterol
can be associated
with vascular disease,
has led to the development of a
class of drugs called statins.
And statins are one of the
most commonly prescribed drugs
out there.
They're a drug that blocks an
enzyme in cholesterol synthesis
and have been very effective at
lowering risk of heart attacks
and strokes.
They've also been
a huge windfall,
a huge moneymaker for lots
of pharmaceutical companies.
And so if you care
about medicine,
they're important to medicine.
If you care about
biotech, they also
were very important
in supporting
the pharmaceutical industry.
All right, now,
we don't have time
to talk fully about how
cholesterol synthesis works.
It's a long pathway.
You can look it up
if you're interested.
You have all the
tools that you need
to understand all of the
steps to make cholesterol.
You'll see you build
it from acyl-CoA.
You need a bunch of NADPH.
I don't have time to go
through all those steps.
But I will discuss
the initial steps,
so you can understand
how statins work.
Because that's important in
medicine, and some of you,
I know, want to go
to medical school.
But apart from that,
these early steps
affect other aspects of
biology, making lipid tails
for signaling proteins,
also introduces
a discussion of
ketones, which are
another important
metabolic fuel that we
need to talk about as well.
Now, the way that one makes
these things is basically you
start with three
acetyl-CoA molecules.
OK.
So here's two
acetyl-CoA molecules.
We can combine those two
together, releasing a CoA.
And this is really
the identical reaction
that we just saw for the early
steps in fatty acid synthase.
OK.
That generates this molecule
called acetoacetyl-CoA.
And then this can combine
with yet another acetyl-CoA
to make this molecule, which is
called Hydroxy-Methyl-Glutaryl,
or HMG, CoA, all right?
I don't need to describe any
of these reactions to you.
As I said, this is just
what we showed earlier
for fatty acid synthesis.
And this reaction is
the identical reaction
to citrate synthase
in the TCA cycle
and takes these three, 1,
2, 3 acetyl-CoAs and makes
this molecule, HMG-CoA.
HMG-CoA is the
substrate for an enzyme
called HMG-CoA reductase.
HMG-CoA reductase
is the famous target
of statins to block
cholesterol synthesis.
What HMG-CoA reductase does
is it releases that CoA group
and uses two NADPH
oxidizing it to two NAD+.
That effectively
is, when you release
this CoA, what are
you're left with?
The acid, you reduce it twice.
And you end up with the alcohol.
And that gives
you this molecule,
which is called mevalonate.
And mevalonate is what you
use to build cholesterol.
And so statins, by
blocking HMG-CoA reductase,
basically block
the reactions that
are necessary to make the
precursor mevalonate, which is
necessary to make cholesterol.
And that's why statins
stop cholesterol synthesis.
Now, mevalonate, it
turns out, is also
used for other things in cells.
It's not just used
to make cholesterol.
It's also used to make
a class of molecules
called isoprenoids.
Isoprenoids are important.
And you'll encounter them if
you study signaling or anything
like that because
these make things
like the farnesylation
lipid modifications that
are oftentimes added to the
membrane associated proteins,
like signaling proteins.
And so statins will also
block the production
of these molecules that are
important for these various
signaling proteins.
And so you should have
some understanding
of what mevalonate is,
where it comes from,
that it's involved in
cholesterol and isoprenoid
synthesis, and that it's
the target of statins.
And of course, you
didn't need a whole lot.
We already have all the tools
to understand that pathway.
And if you look up isoprenoid
synthesis, cholesterol
synthesis, you'll see you'll
have the tools to understand
that as well.
The last thing I
want to talk about
is taking the acetoacetyl-CoA.
And if I take the CoA group
off, what I'm left with
is a molecule called
acetoacetate, OK?
This is basically two
acetyl-CoAs brought together
losing CoAs times 2.
OK.
So this here is acetoacetate.
And acetoacetate is a
canonical ketone body.
What is a ketone body?
Well, it turns out ketones
are an alternative fuel
that the body can use to
glucose, primarily the brain.
And so for reasons that
no one really understands,
a quirk of human and
mammalian physiology,
is that the brain prefers
to use glucose as its fuel.
If glucose is not available,
it doesn't use fatty acids.
It uses ketone bodies instead.
And so the ketone is acetate
is the canonical ketone body.
This underlies the keto diet,
which has become very popular.
And so what is the keto diet?
Well, the keto diet is you
don't eat any carbohydrates.
And so if you don't
eat carbohydrates,
you don't have a
source of glucose.
The liver, of course,
can do gluconeogenesis.
But if you run out of things
to make and turn into glucose,
now the liver gets into trouble.
Remember, we talked about with
anaplerosis of the TCA cycle.
There's no way to turn
two-carbon units that are made
from fat, acetyl-CoA from fat--
mammals cannot turn that
back into glucose because we
don't have the glyoxylate cycle.
And so we can't turn
fat into glucose.
And so when the liver can
no longer make glucose,
it will take acetyl-CoA
from the breakdown of fat
and make ketones instead.
And the ketone is
this acetoacetate.
People do the keto diet because
ketones, like acetoacetate,
will suppress appetite.
And that's at least how one
way it's thought to work.
But I want to talk about
what these ketones are
and how they fit
into metabolism.
So here's acetoacetate.
If you notice, acetoacetate
is a beta-keto acid.
Alpha, beta, the ketone
is beta to the acid group.
So a beta-keto acid,
as I've said now
many, many, many
times, beta-keto acids
can undergo decarboxylation
that generates
the enol, which can be
rearranged to the keto group.
And in that case,
what's the keto group?
Well, the keto group
would be this molecule,
which is acetone,
fingernail polish remover.
If you go to medical
school, you'll
learn that, if type
1 diabetics have
a state of a physiology
called ketoacidosis,
we don't have time to go
into what drives that state,
that physiological state.
But it's basically a state
with very high ketones.
They smell like acetone.
The reason is because
they have very high levels
of acetate, the ketone body.
And some of that spontaneously
carboxylates to make acetone,
all right?
The body does this, though.
It's making the
acetoacetate as a way
to give food to the brain.
But because acetoacetate
is unfavorable,
that's not the form that
is put into the blood.
Instead, it undergoes an
oxidation reduction reaction
where this ketone is
reduced to the alcohol
or interconverted between
the ketone and the alcohol.
Something gets oxidized.
Something else gets reduced.
NAD, NADH is the donor.
And that leads to
this molecule, which
is called beta-hydroxybutyrate.
And beta-hydroxybutyrate
is the canonical ketone
that circulates in your blood.
And measurement of
beta-hydroxybutyrate levels
really tells you
if you're really
doing the ketone diet properly.
So basically, your liver, if
it doesn't have enough glucose,
will have to break down fat.
It can't turn the acetyl-CoA
from fat into glucose.
So instead, it'll turn
it into acetoacetate,
which will convert to the more
stable beta-hydroxybutyrate.
And then the more stable
beta-hydroxybutyrate
can be oxidized by peripheral
tissues, predominantly
the brain, as an
alternative source of fuel
to glucose when the liver
can't maintain glucose.
To why this happens
this way, no one
really knows why it uses
ketones instead of that.
But it fits with
all the physiology,
and it also fits the
metabolism that we've already
learned about to see
why it works this way.
I just want to
point out, for those
of you who are doing the
keto diet, to do it properly.
Yes, you have to
limit carbohydrates.
That's the most
popular way to do it.
But to really make
this work, you also
have to eliminate other
sources of carbon that
can be used for gluconeogenesis,
mostly amino acid,
so lowering protein.
So a true ketogenic
diet is really all fat
because that is what basically
makes acetyl-CoA really
the only carbon source
that the liver can use.
And then it has to only generate
ketones, beta-hydroxybutyrate,
which then circulates as an
alternative oxidizable carbon
source for the brain.
OK.
Thanks so much.